- [Voiceover] The Empire State Building,
the Sears Tower, the
Canadian National Tower,
each of these structures
was the tallest in the world
at the time they were built, or no errors.
So, let's see.
They list a bunch of structures here.
The Empire State
Building, the Sears Tower,
the Canadian National Tower.
And then they talk about
each of these structures.
So really they're talking about
a singular subject right over here, each.
If they said all of these structures,
then we would talk about,
we'd have a plural subject,
but they're saying, "Hey,
take one of these at a time,"
each of these structures
and so this makes sense
that this is was 'cause
was would be the singular
form of the verb, each
of these structures was,
if this was all of these structures,
then we'd put a were there.
They say each of these structures
was the tallest in the world
at the time they were built.
Now, this is interesting.
This is a singular subject,
singular verb, that makes sense,
but then we shouldn't be
referring to they now,
we're talking about
each of the structures,
so it was really at the time it was built,
at the time it was built.
Remember, we're talking about each
of the structures taken individually,
so each of these structures
was the tallest in the world
at the time it was built.
If you wanted to say they were built,
you would have to say
all of these structures
were the tallest in the world
at the time they were built,
but we don't have the option of changing
the each to the all right over here,
so since we're talking
about a singular subject,
we would keep the was
and instead of they were,
it would be an it was,
so let's just read the
whole thing over again.
The Empire State
Building, the Sears Tower,
the Canadian National Tower,
each of these structures
was the tallest in the world
at the time it was built.
Yep, error in part D.